hey guys this is andrew for trading
senses.com and
in this video i want to talk about
golden rule number four
so very quickly i repeat we already saw
before
uh golden rule number one which is to
have a good
proper and strict risk management golden
rule number two
is to have discipline creep record of
your trades
golden rule number three is to uh
not follow the herd because of the greed
and panic
that creates some emotions that make you
take bad decisions
golden rule number four is do not work
only by yourself
let's get into it
so do not work only by yourself
alright this can seem like not
necessary but look look around you
in the finance industry who is making
money
professionals how do they work as
teams look at hedge funds bank banks
are only like different teams working
together when you have a good synergy
asset management all these guys they
work as part of a team
and the reason behind it i will tell you
what is the reason behind us it is that
when you work in a team
you need to justify every decision you
make so it's basically helping you to
have discipline
to stick to your plan all right you
can't just suddenly
change your plan without good
justification
without having good reasons for this if
you work only by yourself
you can change your plan you know
because who do you need to convince
only yourself when you work in a team or
only like a team of two is enough if you
need to
to convince your friend or your
colleague that you want to make
a decision that was not part of the plan
uh trust me
that you need to come up with some
strong uh
evidence that your decision is good so
then you need to think about it and if
actually your decision is not good
you're not gonna find anything
to give to your your the person you're
working with
and to convince them to take this new
decisions that were
not part of the plan so by working as
part of a team
you avoid any bad decisions let me give
you an example that is a personal
example
and that is not exactly related to
finance
but something similar something where
you need to
basically make money by following some
probabilities
and expected gains right this is
poker i used to play poker a lot i was
quite good i was not pro but i was
making money
definitely and i was good at read you
know the situation i was playing a lot
on the internet so some of you guys are
gonna tell me yeah but then
on the internet you cannot read emotions
and stuff like this that's true
i prefer real uh like live poker but on
the internet you have a lot of
information coming from the time
for example the guy is gonna take to uh
to bet
or the contribution that he's gonna make
all the aliens the bluff you know the
the timing before every decision is
crucial
and and of course the decision and the
amount invested
is very important it gives you a lot of
information is he scared
is he feeling confident is he trying to
bluff by showing you too much and he
shouldn't do it if he has a strong game
stuff like this so basically to me poker
is
kind of uh close to technical analysis
when you analyze
some information and statistically you
try to use it to make
money so as i said i was making um some
money i was playing small amounts i was
very young like 10 20
maximum hundred dollars i was betting
but whatever and
i noticed that actually my best results
occurred when i was playing with a
friend so we were basically sitting next
to each other
and playing the same game we were
investing together so it was our money
and basically i was the one that was you
know kind of
leading definitely but i was having
better results because
sometimes after like few hours of of
playing
you are what we call in tilt means
you're taking bad decisions your
emotions are invading you
and then i was sometimes saying all
right let's go lean
and my friend was like looking at me
like hey dude
why would we go in you know we don't
have anything
he looks like he's having a strong game
i can't go in but just give me
some reasons and then i would be like i
have no reason just a feeling
then he would say no man we don't do
this this is not how we play
i don't want to go in and then i'm going
to be yes you're right let's fold it
you know so basically it helps you by
justifying yourself to avoid any bad
decisions and this is the same in
trading all right so work as part of a
team it's even better to have a
community
all right when you can discuss every
decisions you want to take
your analysis so having a community
where you talk about your trades is
very good very helpful and once again
the key is to not only
do it for yourself if you involve other
people's
interests then trust me that every
action you're gonna take
is gonna be justified and better so i
hope
this was helpful guys golden rule number
four is actually
very important and it helps you to reach
the targets of golden rule number two
and number one
discipline risk management all right if
you enjoyed this
please hit the like button and the
subscribe button guys and stay close to
shore